alright it looks like we are now live
for the first monthly AMA here coming
from from our apartment in Wisconsin in
downtown Milwaukee very cold but normal
weather actually that's kind of funny
it's chant recently about you know just
global warming happening hey look how
cold it is now this is nothing compared
to what it used to be like back in 70s
and 80s growing up here where we would
have below zero days on and you know for
weeks at a time but I'm actually kind of
happy that that it's a bit warmer here
alright so I see we've already got a few
people logged in I'm gonna just say a
few things before we actually get
started with questions and comments and
I'll I'll respond to you so the first
thing is I know that some of my viewers
are over in Britain and Europe and some
in northern Africa and parts of Asia so
it's already close to two new years you
know the transition the big midnight
hour so I am actually although it's only
a 12 noon here this is a Sunday I'm
gonna have a beard and and we can toast
towards a successful 2018 this is a
Milwaukee brew I'm kind of partial to
having the local stuff since we have
such a great you know craft brewing
industry here this is from the lakefront
brewery and it's fixed year which is an
American red I PA I particularly like it
so let me say to everybody and if you've
got a glass yourself whatever it happens
to be beer wine champagne whiskey other
drinks tea coffee even if you just got a
glass of water here's to a successful
2018 I think many of us are probably
happy to have 2017 getting behind us but
we've got many challenges ahead
so hope the year is a prosperous and
happy one for all of you and this is
whatever adversities and challenges you
face I hope that you can you can rise to
them and maybe philosophy will play some
some role in that I'm gonna take a look
at the the chat window now you've
already got some some Cheers and some
questions scott is from Chicago and some
people are saying they've got a glass of
water
other people wish they had some some
whiskey all right so let me start with
the first question which is from who saw
our I'm a beginner tell me about some
interesting books in philosophy well
that is like saying take me to the you
know the ocean you know tell me about
which little part of it is the wettest
there's so many things out there that
are really great that you could be you
could be checking out I think that you
know most people given some sort of
support you know like what I provide in
my videos or you find other people
providing in blog posts or other videos
or other resources or up to reading
classic texts in philosophy through them
it doesn't mean you're gonna totally
master understand a philosophical text
the first time around as a matter of
fact that doesn't even happen for most
of us that have been studying them for
years and years I can say that you know
I published stuff on Hobbes Leviathan I
am NOT a master of Hobbes Leviathan but
I would say you know my general advice
is to always start with with Plato and
read some Platonic dialogues they have
the added benefit of actually being
dialogue so you're getting multiple
points of view represented you have to
do some some sort of argument analysis
and critical thinking because sometimes
Socrates you're usually the main
mouthpiece for Plato is gonna make some
bad arguments and you have to be able to
sort of figure out which ones are good
arguments and which ones are bad ones
you know that's where
I would actually start with with
philosophy alright so here's a more
complicated question from somebody who's
got a very complicated moniker j2b to
Nick
lots of Eastern Orthodoxy their
philosophy of theology there seems to be
some animosity between the Eastern
Orthodox churches and the Roman Catholic
Church having to do a st. Anselm Aquinas
original sin figlio quite papacy etc
yeah so and a lot of it has to do with
tendentious and bad readings of what it
is if the other people are saying and
I'll say that that goes on both sides
both you know Catholic people reading
Orthodox stuff and Orthodox people
reading Catholic stuff as an Anselm
scholar I will say that most Eastern
Orthodox takes that I've seen on an
Psalm
really don't don't closely read that the
text in there they're rather tendentious
but you know that's not that big of a
deal because in some is not absolutely
central you know Thomas Aquinas it's
interesting you know Aquinas is getting
the most traction these days not in
Catholic circles but actually in
Protestant circles because they've kind
of rediscovered them in many of the
conservative Protestant churches and
they're finding out that he's not quite
so bad as they thought and he was never
really the official Catholic person
anyway they never really was just one
eastern orthodoxy you know if we look
back to when when there was one big you
could say Christian intellectual
community you know there's a lot of
sharing back and forth before the church
is actually you know effectively split
off from each other linguistic lines and
political lines I I spend a lot of time
reading you know certain authors who are
considered Orthodox right because they
they were in the east but that's just
because I you know kind of a background
and this
you know area of ancient philosophy
moving into the patristic age and and I
think that you know a lot of these
thinkers are quite interesting there is
a lot of unnecessary animosity I would
say it's exacerbated a little bit now
given that the you know the church for a
long time was sort of captive to the
Soviet establishment and now appears to
be somewhat captive similarly to the
Putin regime but you know that's not
only one of many of the the churches
within the Eastern Orthodox spectrum you
could say so probably don't have that
much else to say about that the most
tsukasa asked me cast writes what do you
make of code
ergo sum what do I make of it I mean I
don't make anything of it it's the carts
thing is he right in saying that you
know I think therefore I am because you
know the context there is if I realize
that I am thinking I realize that I that
I exist sure heard himself doesn't think
that gets you very far just the
beginning of his argument then you need
to get to the outside world and to get
to you know my connection to the
external world takes a lot more and
that's what happens in the rest of the
meditations and what happens in the rest
of the discourse Michael drain do you
have any perfect personal ethical views
oh yeah all sorts of personal ethical
views you know you know I think it's
better to tell the truth and then to lie
you know I think that we shouldn't kill
people without having some really great
you know compelling reasons to do so I
think you know we could go on and on and
on it my personal I don't know what you
mean by personal ethical views because
they're not as if I said well I need to
have some some view myself let me pick
something out our views that we have
tend to be kind of a mishmash of things
that we've gotten from a number of
different sources at and thought through
and hopefully in some cases and
maybe we need to think through a bit
more I'll show you this that that when
it comes down to it I'm a virtue
ethicist and I'm an eclectic one so I
draw on the Platonic tradition I draw on
the Aristotelian tradition I draw the
stoic tradition I draw on Christian
thinkers even drew an existentialist and
dialectical thinkers and I don't always
have a really great well worked out the
answer to everything but you know I try
to muddle through as best as I can
Johanna right so which dialogue should
you start with in Plato you know there's
a couple different ways you can go with
that typically we and when I say we I
mean like academic philosophers like
teaching in an intro class we usually
start people out with those you know the
the apology the Euthyphro the the credo
and then the Phaedo that's all the stuff
around Socrates death I also like to
stick in there the me know where you
actually see one of the guys who accuses
Socrates you know coming in and being a
kind of a sore guy in a few minutes and
then leaving and hinting that
something's going to happen to Socrates
and the ion I like to use those six to
start people out the Phaedo is a is a
big and complicated dialogue the other
ones are a bit simpler and they do give
you a sort of robust idea about what
what Socrates is up to and what Plato
saw in him and you get introduced to you
know a number of important like
philosophy like the doctrine of
recollection doctrine of forms the idea
about the immortality of the the soul
those are
but you know learning ignorance or what
one want to be doing but you could just
as well begin by having people read the
symposium or the I've done it before
having them read the gorgeous or the
Republic so I don't think that there is
any one that you you necessarily have to
start with and you know here's the other
thing to keep in mind feed them and then
reread them and get more out of the
rereading than you did out of the
original reading so in a way it doesn't
it doesn't matter so much which one you
start with because you shouldn't you
shouldn't be expecting too much out of
that initial start here's the big
question a very broad one by Jermel what
are your thoughts on the philosophy
community today and or modern philosophy
in general so that's an interesting
thing to ask about because what we in
the philosophy community called modern
philosophy was over about two centuries
ago the modern period begins Renaissance
and for some people includes the
Renaissance but you know we typically
distinguished early modern and
Renaissance philosophy apart from each
other and we could say really ends by
about the 19th century and then you know
we're in a 19th century philosophy some
people like to include some of that in
modern philosophy but but definitely
we're in a a whether you like it or not
a late modern or postmodern age right so
we call that usually contemporary
philosophy and you ask about the
philosophy community so I think that the
academic philosophy community quite
large and parts of it are very
interesting and parts of it are quite
boring I would say that many of the
people working in it are you know not
doing a particularly great job and not
doing a terrible job but many of them
conceive of academic philosophy is
really the only way philosophy really
it's done and and you know it tends to
be channeled in these at least in the
Anglo
fear narrow paths you know analytic
philosophy the traditions that comprise
that you know because there are multiple
traditions within analytic philosophy
that's one one way to go continental
philosophy and other set of traditions
you know we do have people doing
classical American but that's that's
pretty small there are some people doing
comparative philosophy where you're
looking at a non Western philosophy
there are some people still working
solidly within the history of philosophy
/ philosophy as a way of life tradition
which is really where I end up fitting
in these days myself there's a lot of
other things going on as well but
unfortunately I think that academic
philosophy is is you know kind of
moribund it I I engage in it and I enjoy
engaging it but there's a lot of areas
where I'd say it's you know it's not
really doing the job of philosophy that
said you know the philosophy community
also includes like what we're doing
right here the Internet and all of the
things that it makes possible what we
might call public philosophy not
understanding it the way that the people
who build themselves as public
philosophers do because that's actually
very narrow but public philosophy like
where this is public philosophy I'm
engaging with the general that actually
is pretty healthy I think oh there's a
lot of you know there's a lot of stuff
that's not very good you know five
minute videos that get things wrong but
there's also a lot of really great stuff
out there and there's many of us who are
doing a lot of work to try to promote
public philosophy and to do so not only
on the internet but also out their
communities so you know for example I'm
working with a friend and colleague of
mine who runs a tutorial company and
we're trying to establish a chapter of
Sophia the society philosophers in
America here in the Milwaukee area we
started a MKE stoic fellowship you know
we we've got other things going on you
know I do about 20 to 25 free
a year in this local community on one
topic or another many of them partnering
with local libraries so there's a lot of
people out there doing that sort of work
and I think that is quite healthy um
Scott yes are you a fan of the partially
examine life thing to ask about I've
been on their show once I've met one of
the guys face to face I talked with
another one of the guys and I'm not sure
exactly why it is but I've never been
invited on the show again so they didn't
they did extend me the opportunity to
blog on their their site to contribute
content and so far I've written one
piece on epictetus and what is in our
control and I've got a few others in the
works that that I just haven't gotten to
so you know I some some content for them
but although I've reached out to them I
think more than they've reached out to
me particularly interested in having me
collaborate with them I'm not quite sure
why that's that's the case but am i a
fan I think they do good work you know
I myself I suppose I want to do stuff
that that I think is you know really
solidly informed so what I do is a you
know sort of an expert level is a bit
different than the kind of meandering
funny conversations that they have I
think that that it can be a great way to
get people into philosophy and sometimes
you know the conversations that they get
into are very interesting so yeah I
guess I think it's a I'm a fan Scott
Hall writes humanism versus
existentialism any thoughts while there
isn't a versus to begin with I mean read
sart's existentialism is a humanism and
and you'll see that I need to begin with
there isn't one humanism there there
this is an interesting problem in
philosophy right just as there is no one
single existentialism and anybody who
tries to tell you that there is
is one single definite definition of
existentialism don't listen to them
because they're full of full of BS same
thing can be said about humanism there
there are many different human isms out
there and you can say that they share
certain core ideas but there isn't like
a a single version of it any more than
there is with existentialism you know
Sartre is an existentialist can move
despite you know wanting to call
themselves something different is an
existentialist chef stuff is amazing
centralist
Marcel is an existentialist de pouvoir
is an existentialist Kierkegaard is you
know we could go on and on and on and
they're very different from each other
they don't always end up on exactly the
same page so I don't really think there
is a versus there to explore um oh wow
there's a lot of questions here so we're
gonna we got to scroll down or I could
actually scroll up quite a bit
irin edge writes have you read st.
Gregory Palamas
no I haven't Nader pythagoreanism
philosophy of mathematics platonic God
as a mathematician hidden message in
Plato none of those despite having
questions are at this question marks or
actual questions so I'm not sure what
you're asking me about because there's
no there ask thoughts on Jerry Fodor
passing away this past year I didn't
really pay much attention to it because
I've never been I think I may have read
one thing by him back as a graduate
student and then didn't read anything
else Matt writes what would nature
perhaps Aristotle have to say about our
Western your celebrations critic
Nietzsche might object to the lack of
spontaneity in error once you're
scheduled the initiative evel's I don't
think he would object to that
you know the Dionysian rebels were not
all impromptu they were at a particular
time you know that these these
occasional holidays with you know having
kind of a romp and an excess and stuff
like that I think Nietzsche you know
you'd probably say listen this isn't a
lot of the people doing it or doing it
wrong
but you know I think he'd see some some
roll for it there's some opening for
things Aristotle thinks that you don't
want to go too far with those sorts of
things right you don't want to be
intemperate but you know if there is a
time to drink more it probably is during
during a rebel like that I mean I think
Aristotle would probably focus you know
if you look at the NIC and McCain ethics
he one of the key things about his
virtue ethics is he talks about things
like generosity or magnificence how we
how we spend our our money and how we
devote our time do we we try to like
spend it to be a big shot or being
stingy or are we actually being generous
spending on the right things for the
right occasion to create you know
something is he would say something
Noble something something good in the
sense of Agathis right I think that's
where he would be focused and he would
also talk about the the virtue that he
calls friendliness which which involves
sometimes giving pain to people who
you're involved with by not
participating in some of the crazy stuff
that they're doing so you know like if
your friends I can say hey let's play
Russian roulette
you know I think Aristotle would say no
there you should say this is going too
far
I will not participate in it as a matter
of fact give me any two guns you know
Alexander row oh here we mat Gilbert
also says Aristotle catharsis versus New
Year celebrations well I don't know
about that catharsis catharsis means
that you're actually emptied of things
not that you like get totally drunk and
hook up with somebody wake up next to
them the next day wondering where the
hell you are and why you're so hung over
so I you know I don't know if that would
necessarily work for catharsis Alexander
has thoughts on all trite pseudo
philosophy well I don't like pseudo
philosophy of any sort and there's
plenty of it on and all around you know
both in the the traditional right and
the alt-right both on the traditional
left and the radical left you
our progressive left whatever we want to
call it there's a lot of crap philosophy
around all sorts so I I don't I don't
necessarily see it need to isolate it
out like that crap philosophy is crap
philosophy Matthew what's your opinion
of Alvin planting on the sort of
Christian philosophy that he espouses I
read him for a long time I did read his
advice to Christian philosophers then I
brought that up in my book reasons for
told by revelation in a footnote that
you know planting and a lot of the
people that are into it would do a lot
better to have a much wider range of
reading this is one of the problems that
I do see with with the analytic
tradition is that they don't they don't
read an awful lot I think that his
article advice to Christian philosophers
is you know interesting I I don't see it
as you know the revolutionary statement
it's sort of you know it's sort of you
could say locally revolutionary because
that's how how you know that domain that
he was working in was but he anybody who
reads like you know Margaret Ann or
Marcel or blown-down or any these people
would say wow this is reinventing the
wheel and not going quite so far and
reinventing it or you know if you read
you know I would say that you've got
something meteor right there spa I don't
I don't really spend much time on
planting uh I have to say Daniel writes
is a virtue ethicist how happily if at
all do you rely in the writings of
Elizabeth Anscombe I understand her
essay modern moral philosophy was
instrument instrumental and
re-establishing virtue ethics so two
things there how heavily do I rely on
the writings of Elizabeth Anscombe not
at all not heavily I I read her very
very occasionally but I don't see her as
that important you know somebody who I
respect greatly Alastair MacIntyre sees
her as important but I think she was
more important for getting people in
philosophy who weren't already doing
virtue ethics because there were plenty
of people doing it already to take
virtue ethics more seriously but that's
more of a problem with that field
because in you know all the Catholic
schools of course they were still
reading Aristotle and Aquinas and
talking about virtue ethics you know Eve
Simone is a really wonderful book on
virtue
you know from really around the same
time that that she's revitalizing virtue
ethics and he's writing about it in a
way that it's a word that that that you
know lots of people are already using so
I just don't see her I see what she's
doing is interesting and and every once
in a while I'll read her like if I'm
trying to you know grapple with a
particular concept that I think is
useful but I don't really buy this
narrative of like the revival of modern
virtue ethics because it never died it
only died within anglo-american academic
philosophy it didn't die in general and
it was there waiting to be rediscovered
let's scroll down a bit more let's see
here oh pretty how town right is there
value in following one concept such as
justice throughout the history of
philosophy or is it best to deal in
schools of thought like Stoics
pragmatists why not do both this is one
of those methodological questions like
how must I do philosophy well you can do
it in multiple ways and you can do one
first and then do the other next because
you know you're probably going to have
anywhere from depending on how old you
are 10 to 60 years to read this stuff
and Mull it over and think about it so I
think that's that's you know either of
them is a fine choice I mean you're
probably going to end up doing if you're
following one concept out through the
history of philosophy you'd have to
learn a lot about schools of thought
anyway and if you're following out
schools of thought you're going to see
certain common themes coming up over and
over again
so Patrick writes can you give a brief
description of historicism I do not
think I can give a brief description of
historicism so I'm not I'm not even
going to take a stab at it the
complicated topic Eric do you have or
plan to have any videos on Aristotle's
rhetoric yeah that's one I've been
wanting to do for quite a while and I've
been over you know quite a some time
working on Aristotle's rhetoric with a
client and friend of mine and I've kept
thinking well I need to start shooting
some videos on it it's always a question
of when I can get to it I'm a bit behind
this month in what I was supposed to be
shooting Stephen as an eclectic
philosopher what is your definition of
the good life so I'm not a person with
definitions to begin with I think
definitions like like Aristotle says
very often are things we work towards
rather than things we begin from you
know I would I would rather just say how
do I characterize the good life and
there on you know fairly Aristotelian I
think that you know virtuous activity is
at the center of it I'm not sure I agree
entirely about you know what virtue
constitutes you know with Aristotle or
what the virtues with a list of them are
I draw many other people I do think that
we do need relationships friendship I
think that we do need to cultivate some
means and you know it is important to
pay attention to some of the things that
the Stoics call preferred in different
externals and I also you know set a high
regard on intellectual activity usually
it winds up you know it's it's because
of what we get out of it you know I'm in
some respects much more practically
oriented than than purely theoretically
oriented than many of my peers and I
also think that they're gonna we can
learn a lot about what's needed for the
good life from other thinkers so for
example rio maria rilke the the poet and
an essayist and and letter writer and
novelist his conception of sala
to to something I've been thinking quite
a lot about for a number of years and
and you know trying to figure into that
it doesn't fit well into virtue ethics
you know by the way let me say one thing
to when you when you do virtue ethics I
think one of the things that's really
important to avoid is superficial izing
the virtues don't try to turn everything
into a virtue because it's not you know
I see all these crazy schemes out there
where people have like 99 different
virtues and you know each of them winds
up just being a catchphrase that doesn't
provide us with much guidance at all
what's your opinion on Infinite Jest
I haven't read it so I don't have an
opinion far amok I've heard from a
philosophy group I used to attend with
the primary philosophy and academia that
is popular is analytic philosophy and
that now critical philosophy is becoming
dominant do I agree I mean it's better
than we're we're talking about in the
world here in the United States analytic
philosophy is pretty dominant critical
philosophy could mean a lot of different
things and I think there's a number it's
sort of like humanism existentialism
it's not just one one single thing that
we can point to there is you know a good
bit of stuff that we can call a critical
philosophy oftentimes it's done from a
largely analytic perspective do those as
necessarily different from each other
you know analytic philosophy is probably
going to retain its dominance within the
Academy even though it's kind of lost
its its center just because there's not
a lot of people who are willing to put
in the time to actually read through
classic texts and sort of recover of
what philosophy was doing before you
know the analytic movement became
dominant
okay let's see here mark yes do you see
any problem with in Aristotle's thought
if species are created or go extinct no
not really because I'm not I'm not
wedded to Aristotle's biology no no any
we were Sicilians today who are so we
generally just kind of put that stuff
aside and we focus on the other things
market asked about this in another
context you know can we say that there's
a human essence if you know we believe
in something like evolution sure that's
that's comment into being and so long as
that species is still around that
essence will be what it is and we you
know when it comes to rational animal
what's really cool about that is we I
don't think we've completely exhausted
figuring out what that essence actually
includes at this point in time is it
possible to formulate the perfect theory
of ethics one without internal
contradictions if no is it because of
imperfect knowledge of fundamental
differences between people I don't know
I mean is it if you're asking about sort
of a negative of a negative you know is
it possible to have a theory that has no
internal contradictions that anybody
could ever discover you know I mean it's
possible for me to find a theory that at
least for me doesn't seem to have
internal contradictions but maybe I'm
maybe I'm mistaken about that right is
it possible to say once and for all
definitively that whatever theory we've
got that we has settled on is the last
theory of ethics has no internal
contradictions that we won't discover
one if we look more closely probably not
you know but I don't know that I don't
know that we need a perfect theory of
ethics to begin with and I don't know
that lack of internal contradictions is
the only criteria that we're interested
in anonymous right why are there not
many Spanish philosophers also why are
there few famous Spanish philosophers
compared to English France and Germany I
don't say that I don't think there's not
many Spanish philosophers I'm
known quite a few of them you know and I
like some quite a bit like Miguel de
Unamuno and Forte Gossett you know maria
zambrano i would say that well of course
there's that whole Iberian school of
scholastic philosophy that includes like
you know John Paul saw and all that so
you know I wouldn't say that there
aren't many Spanish philosophers I would
say that one of the issues is that we
don't get exposed to them in part
because they're not being they're not
being read and they're not being
translated it's the same issue with the
Tattaglia philosophers or philosophers
in in you know Eastern Europe it's
easier to find stuff in French in German
in in English for philosophers French
and German tend to be you know when you
have to go and study a research language
although a lot of people kind of kind of
you know find easy shortcuts to not
really learn a research language just to
satisfy the requirement but those who do
it seriously often do French and German
and they don't do Spanish or Italian or
Danish or you know pick whatever you
want so I think it's it's it's not as if
there aren't Spanish philosophers as a
matter of fact you know we've got if we
think about the spanish-speaking world
there's outside of Spain as well all
over the place and so it's just a
question of finding them and you know
translating them unfortunately myself I
don't read Spanish I can make out in
academic Spanish some of what's being
read or some of what's being said
because of my
[Music]
you
all right so I am back I don't know what
happened here it seems like we lost
internet for a minute there's something
going on in town something weird and
wonky all right so I was addressing a
question about film and what it what it
is that I would do would I would I do
some videos on some film stuff and the
answer is yes but I would have to find
the time so that is that's probably
something I could put in there is like a
milestone for my patreon levels you know
once I reach certain levels of support
I'll be able to find more time to do
those sorts of things because I do have
to earn a living and much of how I earn
a living is not in traditional academia
you know I teach an odd course here and
there everything else is either patreon
or tutoring or philosophical counseling
or speaking all of those sorts of things
or the courses that I offer so so I'll
say yes I may do that down the line
Christian rights do you have any
opinions on Leo Strauss yeah actually
he's an interesting guy
I don't really like Strauss Ian's very
much because they tend to be kind of
clannish and I don't buy this esoteric
at you know exoteric thing that Strauss
was really big on so you know I do read
Strauss and I actually have used him in
some of the articles that I write
Mohammed can you briefly talk about
artificial intelligence from a nominal
logical perspective so the key word
there's briefly three hints Cristo I
really can't talk about it briefly from
a phenomenological perspective there's
so much involved in both of those so I'm
gonna I'm gonna pass on that one ty says
the only Khemu I've read is the book I
recall dr. Sandler was not entirely
representative him name would stranger
yeah as a matter of fact I do have some
plans to bring out some come move videos
sometime this current here because
eventually for working with a client
right now where we are
you know you know people been looking
forward to this the rebel and I need to
do some videos on that there's also some
really cool essays in this resistance
rebellion and that you know what the
letters to a German friend and some of
the the other things that they have to
say let's see John writes do you have
routine for keeping up with your
languages so they all remain fresh in
your mind I try but I don't I don't
usually succeed in in making time to
read something in them as regularly as I
can and I do every once in a while
that's actually something I want to
start doing more this year I go back to
my my grammars for for Latin the Allen
and green oh and for Greek my Smyth and
I'll you know read sections of it do you
like one one idea or one key linguistic
concept each day and that helps keep
things fresh in my mind those are good
too because they have lots of examples
in them here's a here's a cool question
one of my favorite works of fiction so I
think I'm actually gonna do a video
about that sort of like to ten you know
ten philosophers I bring to a desert
island like my 10 favorite ten favorite
fiction writers they would definitely
include like philip k dick and bor hast
Dostoevsky
you know Irish Murdock Graham Greene you
know those are those are people that I
oftentimes go back to to enjoy their
their works and if I ever find like a
work that I haven't read before
somewhere around a shelf I'm happy to to
dig into that I also really like Lucian
I guess you could consider him a fiction
writer he did write the first science
fiction thing with a true history Derek
asked could you briefly elaborate on
your opinion of lab chest off you're one
of the few people I've ever heard bring
him up have yet to find a reliable
translation of his work so if you if you
know other
translations are reliable or not that
means that you read him in Russian which
is pretty amazing of course if you're
reading Athens Jerusalem
that's that's it you know originally in
French because it's published as a set
of articles in the review tomato
physique and we're all and then
published as a portal I can say Athens
in Jerusalem the translation that's
pretty good from what I can tell yeah
chef stuff is one of these underrated
thinkers and he kind of fell through the
cracks in you know the period that I do
a lot of work on in in you know like
20th century France but he never really
caught on here I'd say in the
english-speaking countries he's a really
I I really enjoy his work I find him
very insightful me he's is anti-systemic
he tries to out Kierkegaard Kierkegaard
in his book on a guard once he discovers
him he's one of the first people to
start seeing and writing about the
connections between Dostoevsky Nietzsche
and bringing in other authors like
Tolstoy Trek off you know he's one of
the second generation existentialist I
think he's must read whether his stuff
is is good translations or not I don't
know Russian sub
Ice Age technology is stoicism and
sports incompatible boy you're really
throwing me a softball with that one
aren't you because I just published a
piece in stoicism today about being a
Packers fan so you know I don't know if
you've read it or not or whether you're
indeed lobbying me what we call a
softball so I can hit it out of the park
but that what's a pretty easy one
Matt Matt writes any thoughts on Robert
Pirsig you know I read zen and the art
of motorcycle maintenance when I was a
teenager I think I read it again in
college I you know I I think it's one of
these problems where had been talked up
to me so much that I was like oh there's
gonna be amazing when I read this and I
was a bit disappointed
it is a book actually that I plan to go
back to and reread in order to do some
video stuff about just to see whether
maybe I was wrong about it or whether it
is kind of overrated I don't really know
where do you asked what philosophy
Center podcast would you recommend to an
intermediate learner I don't really
listen to many podcasts so I contribute
to podcasts more than I listen to them I
would say in part because my time is so
scarce I really am a fan of the flat
history philosophy with no gaps they
listen to quite a bit of that so I would
what I would recommend marki yes do you
think Bitcoin will fulfill Nietzsche's
prophecy I don't know what prophecy so
and I don't know enough about but could
I really say
Oh
John has got a good question how long
did it take before you felt confident
saying you could read Latin and Greek
and how different is reading ability in
an ancient language from a modern one so
let me answer the second one I'd say
it's not that different I mean you you
know you read different kinds of
language so I very I can very easily
read academic articles because I'm used
to certain vocabulary right but if I
pick up something that's supposed to be
like Sporting News in German or French I
don't know what a lot of the words mean
fascinated when I when I find it like
you know oh pitcher in baseball is
Lasser that's that's so interesting you
know but I don't think that reading I
mean it's different reading that
language from reading the other language
Latin is a very different language than
say some of the languages that develop
from it like friendships in the way you
know syntax works and all of that now
how long did it take before I felt
confident in saying I could read it you
know a few years
the the question is you know how often
you need to like go back to the lexicon
or to the grammar to figure out what the
hell's going on in there and that kind
of depends on the author you know like I
can pick a barrister but read Aristotle
or epictetus no problem but if I'm
reading Plato I'm going back and forth
the lexicon all the time you know and
same thing with with certain other
authors you kind of get used to reading
certain authors j2b - Nick are you
familiar with dr. edward festered I'm
familiar with them I don't read him
because you know again I don't know the
time and I'm not very interested in what
he's doing I suppose I should you know
when I do stuff on philosophy and
religion but I prefer to stick with you
know the primary facts mmm let's see
here
dude Tolliver asks do you ever do
mathematics anymore read philosophy of
math very rarely unfortunately that's
something that I really enjoyed spending
time with mathematics but again I don't
have that much time for it I'll get out
one of my text books which are probably
you know pretty out of date I mean it's
not like the mathematics is bad but I'm
sure there's there's better ways to
teach it there explain things I don't
once in a while I'll I'll read something
in philosophy of math you know go over
the library and get get some can't or
you know dig my way through girdle
Escher Bach you know stuff like that but
I just don't find the time for it and
then it is something I would like to
find the time for because I really did
enjoy philosophy and mathematics
um weekly Bible talk strongest critique
of tome ISM I don't have one I'll say
this tome ISM is like one of those words
like existentialism or humanism if you
tell me somebody's it's hummus I always
want to know what kind because there are
so many different versions of tome ISM
out there and many of them don't have
that much connection to actual Thomas
Aquinas I mean I'm out you know if
somebody is like quoting Gary Guler
garage at me or quoting Jacques Maritain
I don't like Gehrig ulla garage I do
like Jack more akin and they're not
actually bringing it back to Thomas I
don't consider them a Thomas here it's
homeless if you actually focus on Thomas
and don't worry so much about what the
commentators say I think that you know
it can become like anything else it can
be done in crappy ways that wind up
being very schematic some of the people
that are into Thomas
I call them fundamentalists of the soma
because they they're like you know I
just got to find the right proof text
Thomas has the answers to everything no
if you really are at oh madness that
means to like take on the spirit of how
Thomas approached things which means to
try to take in as much as possible and
work out some some new synthesis of
ideas to try to approximate it if all
you're talking about is like Oh Thomas
is about realism or stuff like that
I'm not quit being interested when
people talk in that that way Eric what
are your thoughts on transhumanism well
something that I haven't devoted enough
attention to in terms of like reading
primary text on but it's a very
interesting phenomenon certainly is
something that I think has classical
predecessors you know in in modern
philosophy even in ancient philosophy to
a certain extent you know in certain
speculations that people have I think
that people often look at it as if it's
like the new wave and and we got to get
into this I don't see I don't see a lot
of those promises you know is likely to
be fulfilled but they're interesting to
theorize about let's see here it asks
who is your favorite philosopher and
please elaborate on why as well as
taking account of time and space in your
life at this period well that's a tough
question for me I don't I don't know
that I have a favorite philosopher I
think you know gone through many phases
where I certainly did have a favorite
philosopher but I don't think I can say
that I do now
I mean there there are people who I
return to over and over again and really
enjoy you know say Gabrielle Marcel and
Maurice Blondell Alistair McIntyre of
course who I can I can say is actually
the real deal when it comes to virtue
ethics I've met him personally
you know Aristotle Plato Plutarch Cicero
I really love you know in all sorts of
other people in between I don't know
that I can actually say that I have a
favorite
same thing for Caesar Augustus was your
most favorite piece of philosophical
literature I don't think I have a good
answer than that well here's a here's a
here's a not a question but a comment
and I've got a great response to this
fester is wonderfully smug in his
refutation of New Atheism well that's
great
because the end of the New Atheists are
smug in town as well so you got you got
you know smug religious people on one
side smug a theist people on the other
side they can fight with each other and
in the meantime I don't have to bother
with them and I can get on with the task
of actually like doing philosophy
so Daniel no what do you think of
Buddhist philosophy I wish I had the
time to devote to studying more of it I
used to when I when I taught in the
prison I used to teach quite a bit of
Buddhist thought and well a lot of other
stuff too because I was teaching
comparative religion every semester and
and going into doing a lot of research
and I also didn't have any committee
obligations or anything like that it's
been quite a while since I've looked at
looked at very much of it in any
anything less than a superficial way on
my own part so I don't really have any
any thoughts it's something there's a
you know great tradition that I wish I
could had the time to participate in
will ask do I read any works of land at
Benoit
no I don't I haven't at this point
Francis asked a really interesting
question people ask about mastery of
different fields and discipline what
would a master of philosophy look like
well well so that's a great great
question I I guess from where I set you
can talk about mastering a particular
domain or field or something like that
but in my view you haven't mastered it
if you haven't read at least some of the
read and really understood the major
thinkers in that field so if all you've
done is read a set of articles from the
last 20 years about you know the self in
analytic philosophy and you've really
read those very thoroughly and you
haven't read a card and you haven't read
the Hume and you haven't read haven't
read Aristotle well you're not a master
of that topic so yeah
Toliver has a kind of goofy question you
study the philosophy of aaron rodgers I
don't know that Rodgers has a philosophy
I mean I be happy to talk with him about
that he's just up the road in Green Bay
but I don't know that he would have the
time or the interest or inclination
about that but if anybody knows you know
a way to make that happen that would be
super cool you know I think I will say
this about aaron rodgers those who don't
know who we're talking about he's the
quarterback for the Packers he's at an
elite level of performance he's one of
the main reasons why the Packers have
been such a powerhouse team over the
last you know a decade or so and he got
injured this year and that was a real
problem for us injured for you know this
is the second time he's been injured in
a major way in his career there's is
very good at telling the team to relax
to you know to take things one step at a
time and so if he does have a philosophy
I guess that that's it and I think that
that's that's pretty good
yay Zeus rates any thoughts on John
Searle
no not really it's been a long time
since I've read his work he's you know
somebody important to read and analytic
philosophy and philosophy of
consciousness but it'll really have much
to say Scott can you explain plato's
relationship with Socrates well he was a
student of Socrates and he's one of the
main ways in which we do know about this
guy Socrates he's not the only student
of Socrates several others started
philosophical schools including antis
tonie's who was the the other guy starts
in Megerian school
Euclid I think it was and then we of
course have Aris Tippa starting the
Syriac school and and although he
doesn't start a school Xenophon is a
very important student of Socrates as
well we get a lot of you know
Socrates ideas through Plato but also
through Xenophon and you know Socrates
winds up being an important mouthpiece
for Plato for his own ideas as well
let's see dreama can you do videos on
ethics and veganism I think that's the
sort of thing where you know either
way way way way down the line where you
know like I'm really
earning a sufficient income on patreon I
would I would do you know like maybe
ethics of all sorts of things or if you
want to Commission me to do a video on
something like that I would but that's
that's that's probably not something
that I have in mind to do right away
viola what's the best way to teach
philosophy in your opinion I don't know
I don't know that there's a best way to
teach philosophy I send her on primary
text so I have students engage with them
because I have confidence in students
and I don't want them just to get stuff
through a textbook but I give them a lot
of support you know and I do a lot of
try to find good examples that they can
latch on to and help them you know
conceptualize what they're doing and I
also believe in a lot of applications so
if we're talking about an idea from the
Aristotle I want the students to be able
to find some way to apply it to their
own life
from their experience okay boo scrolling
down synth must I guess is how to say it
have you studied any libertarian right
thinkers anarcho-capitalism
non-aggression principle consistently
applied what do you make of it do you
have a political philosophy position
yeah I've studied some of that stuff but
I don't I don't spend a lot of time on
it
again this is something that once I
reach a sufficient level on patreon I'd
probably do some videos about cuz I've
committed to doing like a whole
political series and most of what I do
is actually read read blogs by people
who either went to school with her I'm
colleagues with and who I know who are
into that sort of stuff and and see what
they're they're debating and talking
about like you know for certain
magazines like Reason magazine right
time going back to primary text for that
although you know like I said there's no
reason why I couldn't down the line
let's see remixes vegetarianism a
disease well if it is then then my wife
is sick actually uh uh you know she is a
vegan for health reasons because it
helps her out you know and I think like
when you talk about vegetarianism or
veganism there's like a whole spectrum
of different different things you know
I've known some people who are pretty
cool
I actually just been whipped up five
quarts of vegetarian chili yesterday
actually it's strictly speaking vegan
too because you know that that's healthy
and that's what we eat I'm not I'm not a
vegan myself or a vegetarian I do eat
meat but I may end up you know stopping
doing that because I'm very concerned
about what what factory farming does so
I don't see any reason that kind of
trivialize it that way
Mohammed when will you if possible do
Eastern or mid Eastern philosophy that's
a good question
so I don't like to
to do videos on people and text unless I
really understand them well so that that
narrows my range considerably you know
when it comes to like the Arabic
thinkers it were really privileged here
in town I you know Marquette University
where I was teaching for last semester
just as a one-off one of my colleagues
there is Richard Taylor and he started
the Aquinas in the Arabs project and so
they do a lot of stuff on Islamic
philosophy and he's got graduate
students learning Arabic and and
sometimes Syriac and things like that so
they can they can read these these texts
and it's really you know pretty cool to
go to that and also to go to the annual
Aristotle the Aristotelian tradition
conference because I get to hear about
you know what's going on in Averroes are
all Farabi or stuff like that but I
don't really know them well enough to
say much intelligently about them I
would have to do quite a bit of research
similarly I you know I have an interest
in Chinese philosophy but although I've
made a few efforts that I don't read
Chinese you know and I'm very dependent
on other people's translations so you
might say the same thing too about me
reading in Spanish or talking about
Dostoevsky but I I you know I would have
to get to the level where I actually
feel confident enough to do stuff on
that Eric would you do any videos on G K
Chesterton yeah that's actually a good
thought he by the way
hey is what I'm really enjoy reading
mark Wright's wisdom temperance courage
and justice any priority to any one of
these well if I if I go by my own
productivity's and temperament courage
that's the problem with me I am you know
if we use like sort of the Platonic
classification I'm not one of those wise
people
well I'm one of those through monic
people watch with anger and have had so
many obstacles to overcome which led me
to do research on anger throughout my
entire life
to Nietzsche for well I think right and
you know which one should get priority I
actually would probably say justice I'm
supposed to say wisdom is a philosopher
but I probably say justice okay
all righty yes thoughts and philosophy
studies leading to Buddhist philosophy
existentialism particularly for me I
mean you know it leads to Buddhist
philosophy studying Buddhist philosophy
you know saying I want to study Buddhism
I mean if existentialism leads you to
Buddhism great I don't know how it would
it sure as hell wouldn't for me but you
know I suppose you know Hume had some
connections apparently with Buddhist
philosophy but maybe show up an hour you
know
Nietzsche was always down on the
Buddhists but maybe suddenly he really
some Matt writes any thoughts on Martha
Nussbaum capabilities approach to virtue
ethics and utilitarianism
I actually don't read miss ball much so
I don't know enough about that to say it
I have her at a recent book on anger
which is good in parts and so in other
words and I think is wrongheaded in
other parts it's yeah so I don't
actually have that much to say oh boy
grant according to Plato two opposites
each have a form for for example as
their form of injustice since there's a
form of justice because of how little it
instantiates justice yeah it's the
ladder there there aren't opposite forms
there is a form of justice now what
exactly the form of virtue is that's
tricky I actually did a talk about that
that I eventually intend to write an
article about because it's not like form
of you know or man or things like that
what exactly is the form of Justice or
courage or temperance that's how in
order to say so that's worth some
thinking about but yeah there isn't a
form of injustice and you know Plato has
Socrates also say look there there
aren't forms of mud or you know hair or
things like that
well here's a great question from
bare-root are you worried about the
future of humanities academia in America
I'm not because I'm not in academia and
I don't think that philosophy just has
to get done or the humanities in general
just has to get done in at the at the
academy I think if the Academy doesn't
do a better job not only of you know
doing its own internal work but outreach
including to the people who want to cut
their jobs if they don't start learning
how to actually speak to them instead of
just criticise them well then maybe they
deserve to go it's not like philosophy
is going to disappear if we close down a
bunch of philosophy departments the rest
of us are still going to be doing it out
here and still explaining it and still
we're still gonna be reading to cart'
and Berkeley and gaggle and all those
people so I'm not particularly worried
about that I think the people in
academia ought to be very very worried
and if they're interested I can give
them plenty of advice a lot of it is the
stuff that they probably should be
thinking of anyway you know I'll give it
a great example of this when I was still
at Fayetteville State University which
is a historically black college in in
North Carolina really interesting origin
story had fallen on hard times I was in
the University Senate and North Carolina
is an incredibly contentious place as
far as politics goes in education so you
know there were all these budget cuts
across the board official crisis hit and
the Republicans were really trying to
use this to do as much damage to the
university system as possible and even
if they could close a couple HBCUs and a
lot of it just has to do with who votes
for who and all that on the other hand
within Fayetteville State University a
Republican could do no good whatsoever
and anything they said was automatically
going to be attacked there was a kind of
a group thing coming in and so it was
kind of unhealthy on both sides and I
remember being in the Senate and
during this discussion going on about
you know what was happening up in
Raleigh and how you know choices are
gonna be made about the institution and
budgets and stuff like that and I got up
and I said listen why don't we actually
send a delegation up there to talk to
these Republicans and say you're being a
little bit short-sighted you know we're
not your enemy we're trying to do a good
job educating and important you know
part of the population and they just
looked at me like I was crazy and I was
like listen if you don't want to talk to
your the people that you consider
enemies don't be surprised when they
when they cut your programs so I think
there's a lot of that in academia
there's there's a kind of entitlement
mentality that well just because we've
had philosophy departments or history
departments they ought to continue to
exist maybe they do maybe they should
continue to exist probably they don't
they shouldn't continue to exist with a
current staff of them maybe a lot of
people should have to like reapply for
their jobs maybe eat a lot of the people
who are doing adjunct work deserve those
full-time positions better than the
people the full-time positions I don't
know there's a lot to be said here so
you only ask a question they don't
actually have a good question for what's
the limit between categorical an
accidental quality not really sure
because I imagine it depends on what
frame of reference fear you're using
there um let's see you're gonna go a
little bit we already already a little
bit over time but we're gonna go to 138
I'll say it's bills I guess is how it's
pronounced are you familiar with the
traditionalist think areas going on
Ebola I'm familiar with them having read
them read losses on them I'm familiar
with traditionalist thinkers who
actually were traditionalists before
those guys came around like Joseph to my
stand
davonne hogs and and lawmen a people
like that because there was an actual
thing called traditionalism in European
philosophy in the nineteenth century and
I and I do read you know some of the
people that some of the traditionalist
into like murky le odd you know reading
and teaching of le odd over the years
but no I can't say know that much about
these traditionalists dudes doctor
sailor are you're a pump they're a
Democrat or a Republican I'm not either
I'm an independent I don't I don't have
a party where I can find a home
definitely wouldn't fit into the
libertarian party
I like the greens because of the
emphasis on the environment but they're
kind of kooky and many other respects
definitely not into the Constitution
party and I didn't actually vote in one
of the primaries here for the pirate
party candidate because we actually had
a pirate party here in Wisconsin Oh
anybody starts like disgust yeah okay
pretty how town all philosophers do is
talk in circles are waiting for
scientific discoveries to move the
goalposts discuss that's so stupid
anybody he actually hadn't who's
actually like looked at the history of
ideas it's almost laughable people say
stuff like that but I mean I don't if
it's there's so many other people out
there who can give a good critique of
that I graduate start because that's so
silly I mean they're there even to like
philosophize about that is already doing
philosophy all right let me I just the
things scroll a bit let's see what we
got here
good to do there's a lot of questions
here probably gonna have to be a bit
more selective boy there's a lot of
questions
let me get here let's see here
whoa ah here we go Daniel asks the music
question what kind of metal do you play
on bass I don't actually play bass
anymore I gave the bass to my daughter
and she plays bass and she likes the
classic stuff she's actually you know
very well educated when it comes to
classic metal but she also likes you
know more contemporary stuff like Black
Veil Brides and Fall Out Boy and all
that whatever that's classified is I
don't know I play the banjo and I tend
to play classic metal you know from
before we start dividing it into genres
and people specializing when it comes to
the genres I do like you know what we
call a new wave of British heavy metal
power metal doom metal thrash although
there's a lot of it when they're just
shredding for the sake of shredding I
can't stand that stuff and what else is
there anything else in there that I'm
particularly into that's pretty much the
gamut you know and so you know I play
banjo and I play guitar parts on it so
I'll play you know UFO a little bit
Black Sabbath some Judas Priest some
scorpions some Motorhead and it really
depends on me finding guitar chords for
the stuff or figuring it out on my own
and I don't practice anywhere near
enough to be to be good at what I'm
doing that's starting to get kind of
dark here I'm gonna turn a bit so so I'm
not so in shadows see here oh great
question
Tony would it be a prerequisite for
world leaders to the background in
philosophy I mean that'd be great
I don't know that looking at the crop of
people who do study philosophy that that
would actually make them better people
they'd have to like take some of that
stuff to heart so you know okay what are
you gonna do um let's see here
mmm to do
scrolling down a bit
Oh dr. Sandler who was the friend is
from Thomas who's the French Hegel he
once mentioned can't find it was at Mara
tan no it's uh Maurice Blondell he was
sometimes called the Catholic Hegel or
the French Hegel guy wrote my
dissertation on you elaborate more on
the stoic idea preferred indifference
I'll do a very quick thing because
there's plenty of stuff you can google
on that so stoic say that there's
there's things that are good things that
are bad and then everything else is
indifferent what's good or virtues
what's bad is vice everything else like
wealth health you know social status
those are all indifference some
different indifference are preferred
which means that they have a positive
value but it's not an intrinsic positive
value and some of a negative ones so it
is it is better all things being equal
to have money then not to have money
because it can conduced it's a living
you know a life of virtue so very before
it so that that's sort of that in a
nutshell all right so what are your
thoughts on Simone vane somebody else
who have read it a little bit of but not
not that much of so thoughts on her kind
of interesting and let's read down an
ordered whole would you ever do a video
where you work through ideas with a
student one on one that's an interesting
idea I mean I could I don't know that it
would make for a really great video you
know it could be interesting to do
that's that's not a bad idea um let me
scroll down a bit more
dude Benjamin are you familiar with karl
popper's critique of Plato yeah read
popper he was obligatory reading when I
was in graduate school not impressed
with him you know he I think he did it -
he wasn't a very good
of the people who he was critiquing the
Republicans is it's not clear that
that's designed to be plato's you know
one time only statement about things all
right
yay Zeus any thoughts on VidCon Steny
was quite popular for a you years few
years I actually did a video on my
VidCon Stinney Enphase I used to be
really into him I think the concern is
an interesting philosopher who had he
read more widely probably would have had
much more interesting stuff to say
unfortunately he didn't um let's see
what else we got here Darren is it true
that the pythagorean's eating beans was
punishable by death
I don't think so they weren't supposed
to eat beans nobody knows why but I
don't think it was punishable by death
Ben I mean what would a modern-day
Pythagorean look like I guess they would
be like totally behind the times because
they they would be just into Pythagoras
and his and they would ignore the rest
of philosophy so I don't know that it
would be very interesting read young I
do read young every once in a while I'm
you know I kind of like more his
critiques of other people's stuff than
his own possitive his own work Matt
Gilbert do you like Iris Murdoch I do
need like Iris Murdoch I like her her
novels and I like her her philosophical
stuff as well Alfred what do you think
about ggx philosophy in general and his
reading of Hegel jeez Nick is kind of
all over the maps I I think when you're
reading Dziedzic on anybody you're
getting more Dziedzic then then that
person same with the lose it can be
interesting stuff oftentimes it's
difficult to follow and there's so many
assumptions that seem to be made that I
can't really
you know I read jejak occasionally I
actually like the stuff that he has to
say about like contemporary politics
more than reading his theoretical works
design Balan have you looked into
computational neuroscience as concerning
transhumanism
that is not something I've had the time
to do other than you know sort of
skimming and you know I mean this is a
hobby horse of mine a lot of what passes
is neuroscience I think is really neuro
pseudoscience just adding the word neuro
to stuff there there really is some good
stuff out there but a lot of it you know
the conclusions that they would be
warranted and drawing are much much much
narrower all right demons hunter what
are some philosophers everyone should
read the classics Plato Aristotle Cicero
what we've got a bit bit curious you
know Xenophon you should read to the
Stoics sexist empirica you know and then
continue on into you know middle and
neoplatonist pagan Christian and Jewish
like feeling loved Alexandria you know
and we could go on and on and on right
yeah everybody should read some Hume to
what here's a good one what to Jay to be
Nick what are your general thoughts on
scholasticism are the most common
critiques against it valid
so scholasticism again it's something
that doesn't have one single meaning and
you'd have to say like whose
scholasticism to say whether the common
critiques are valid I will say that
there is there are some great scholastic
thinkers and there are some scholastic
thinkers that make philosophy into just
cookie-cutter [ __ ] I would also say
that many of the people who are assesses
Mehran and criticize that are often
quite scholastic themselves and a lot of
contemporary analytic philosophy looks
very much like
what what scholasticism had to generate
it into you know what the early modern
attack them them for um let's see here
Christopher says I heard you say in a
past video you don't particularly care
for Spinoza and I was curious as to why
I disliked Spinoza I don't like Spinoza
I think he's overrated I think a lot of
people get really sort of infatuated
with them I distrust many of the people
who say that they they do understand the
perspective and the ethics the ethics is
a very difficult book to read and make
sense of I think a lot of people are
attracted to Spinoza ISM without
actually reading Spinoza again you know
doesn't mean I dislike him I read him
and I teach him so you know I mean end
up doing videos Adam some some somewhere
down the line I'm gonna try to skip over
some of the questions that are gonna be
really hard to answer for me at this
point in time he was a good one
Francisco what advice would you give a
20 year old well you know sock away
money enjoy yourself in your body while
it lasts
don't be obsessed if you're in college
with getting out too early because the
job market sucks and you got plenty of
your life to live take the opportunity
to study as much as you can and you know
when it comes to relationships the ones
that you're engaging in as a 20 year old
to be the one necessarily it could
happen but but oftentimes it's it's not
what do you think of American pragmatism
or neopragmatism seems to bridge the gap
between analytic and continental styles
you already Putnam and Dewey
yeah that's Rory's line isn't it and
that that's true
no it's it's it's a strain of its own
and in many respects it's closer to
history of philosophy and continental
philosophy than it is to analytic
philosophy I have great respect for
Josiah Royce
William James CS purse and even going
back further you know I like the trans
transcendentalist and I like Jonathan
Edwards I like the American Renaissance
people and I don't mean the
neoconservatives you know people I mean
the people from the actual American
Renaissance which would include people
like William Jefferson and you know the
founding fathers all that I mean you
know where I went to school lots of do
Ian's I've never found Dewey to be a
great thinker and I think that that
people who are going to do we tend to be
kind of cultist about it as thing in the
world
then that's my experience so yeah I
think classical American philosophy is
pretty cool let's see here
grant have you read Zetas funds memoirs
of Socrates yep
I haven't needed read it many times I'm
a big fan of Xenophon and I came quite a
lot Mark Trumbull our essence is real
depends on what you mean by essences and
depends on me but a real so let's see
here Wow then then you mean rights
a few years ago I decided to finish
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit before I
turned 18 that is dedication
Wow that's tough let me skip down a bit
more do a lot of back and forth going on
here in the comments between people oh
here's a good one from Nam I plan to
spend my 2018 reading about
existentialism I some literary works of
Camus Sartre and currently reading
either/or but that said any advice on
which books I should focus on I would
say you know start you want to start
with Kierkegaard of course and then you
want to read definitely want to read
sickness unto death and if you're in
trembling as well and probably
philosophical fragments that's good to
read as well don't read more kick a
guard there's plenty of others but
that's that's already quite a bit and
then you get Dostoevsky to read and
there of course you know you're looking
at novels don't jump right to the
brothers karamazov read some of the
other stuff first read read the notes
from the underground definitely and read
um you know the idiot and the that's
translated is either the demons or the
possessed that's that's a wonderful book
I actually like that better than
brothers Karma's off myself and then
read Brothers Karamazov and maybe Crime
and Punishment
Nietzsche and then if you want to be
kind of systematic read some gear on
days who was one of the people
recognizing that there was a connection
between these thinkers Dostoevsky to
Nietzsche
and then you know love chests off of
course Rainer Maria Rilke a read his his
letters to a young poet some of his
poetry I would start with the book of
hours you know do we know elegies
although those are difficult and his his
novel I'm blanking it on it right now
but yeah you can be confided easily
yeah Spurs well worth reading him
Heidegger you want to read you want to
read in addition to start you want to
read a Simone de Beauvoir two and
Gabrielle Marcel and that'll keep you
busy for the year I think right so
that's good alright I just scrolled
again
okay oh here's an interesting one by
chicken wing you mentioned in another
vid how you studied both philosophy and
math and undergrad what was that like
did you enjoy your time as an undergrad
Brittany's favorite classes yeah I
joined my time as an undergraduate you
know I came in having been in the Army
for a while and then you know thinking
into and I also worked in a restaurant
for a bit too you know I did my classes
pretty seriously I also screwed around a
lot you know great woods and River
behind the school behind the campus and
I'd go out there and like run and an
explorer and did my you know my share of
drinking and screwing around and I had
it had a good time I also did you know
do a lot with the mathematics at one
time I thought maybe I want gone to
graduate school in mathematics or maybe
take the actuarial exams but philosophy
I didn't get a little burnt out towards
the end you know I had what you call
senioritis and were there any classes I
really didn't like what the classes you
know can't think of any that I that I
didn't like offhand
so yeah I'm gonna skip down a bit
so here's an interesting remark Matthew
well-educated about metal sounds like
someone talking about classical music
well metal has been around for a long
enough time that I think we can start to
talk about it in those ways you know
I'll get on my soapbox here the people
who buy into the narrative about heavy
metal that first it was Black Sabbath
with you know also Led Zeppelin and deep
purple kind of playing some metal stuff
as well and then it was this wasteland
and nobody was doing it until Judas
Priest came on the scene which is a
story that Rob Halford tells you know
when you see them at concerts and stuff
that's totally BS I mean there were a
lot of great metal bands in the 70s
doing some really cool stuff and you
know if you're an enthusiast about it
you you probably know some of this from
like having been around and listened to
things and you know you start thinking
about well okay who's important and who
influenced who you know and how you know
what counts as metal and where should we
just call it electronic or hard rock or
space rock or or you know whatever else
we want to think about you know these
are valid questions and and and I think
this is an interesting field of study
aughter got kind of introduced Tripp
just because of my own interest in it
and so that gave her a sort of advantage
she's the kind of person of course
where's the ac/dc shirt that all the
kids are wearing these days but she
knows who UFO are and why they matter in
the history of metal she understands how
you know Michael schechner joining the
group changed the dynamic you know all
those sorts of things so there is
something to that Daniel writes metal is
the direct descendant of classical yes
classical but also blues and also
foreign influences as well so it is
connected with with that
let's see dudes right so if you could
get any guy for the pass to get to lead
the u.s. who would you choose I don't
know that it would be a politician I
don't actually have to think about that
more the u.s. is a real mess at this
point in time who's my favorite African
American philosopher I actually did get
to teach one one section of an African
American philosophy at FSU firfer uh it
was a joint thing too it was connected
with some other classes it was kind of
fun
I know whom I really enjoyed reading the
most probably W Dubois you know the boys
you know I was Frenchified unfortunately
I'd say he's probably for me sing ones
um alright so scrolling down hmm
find a good thing to finish up on since
we're already like about an hour and a
half beyond Oh Lew clan what do you
think of the future of academic
philosophy it seems we haven't had a
groundbreaking philosophy book written
in many years so I don't know that we
need a groundbreaking philosophy book I
think that plenty books out there that
nobody can read them anyway I mean I
would say that Alistair McIntyre's they
have two virtue which is a Middle East
from 80s as a groundbreaking book that
comes to mind that I would say are that
important probably not but I don't know
that we need groundbreaking books I
think it's enough that we have already
and keep working through it so
uh you know I I always wanted to write a
groundbreaking book but now I just wanna
like do good videos and when I do get
around to my book writing projects which
I've been laboring at for a while I just
want them to be books that are useful I
don't expect them to you know totally
transform the philosophical scene we're
so wet we're so lucky with how much we
currently have access to and the fact
that we can connect in this way that I
think may be enough groundbreaking books
to sort through in the rest of our life
all right so I didn't I didn't actually
get to everybody's questions I see some
other ones here but I'm going to bring
this to a close because I do have a few
other things to do including getting
myself some lunch
so roofer for joining me for for this
this hangout if you want to contribute
on patreon I know somebody here said
that they already joined on patreon if
you like the work that I do that's a
great way to help support let me give
one more toast all of you have a safe
prosperous and intellectually enjoyable
New Year of 2018 coming up and I will
see you on the other side of it